un nuevo operativo israelí en si
Jordania ocupada causó este jueves otra
muerte Palestina en jenning en un
tiroteo con soldados israelíes un joven
de 17 años Se recibió un disparo en la
cabeza según informó el Ministerio de
salud palestino el ejército de Israel se
encontraba allí para localizar las
viviendas de dos palestinos asesinados
el miércoles en otro intercambio de
fuego cerca del puesto militar de silboa
hecho que también se cobró la vida de un
oficial israelí precisamente Israel
suele demoler las casas de las familias
de los palestinos acusados de cometer
atentados incluso antes de que exista
una condena una política denunciada por
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos por
tratarse de un castigo colectivo estos
últimos hechos han elevado al menos 84
la cifra de palestinos asesinados en sí
Jordania por fuego israelí el mayor
registro en siete años disparado por las
incursiones casi diarias de las fuerzas
israelíes en ciudades como jenning ona
blues a partir de una serie de ataques
en marzo y abril que dejó 18 israelíes
muertos Israel ha intensificado estas
operaciones que califica contra
terrorismo acusando de inacción a la
autoridad Palestina está a su vez
asegura que las incursiones y las
políticas israelíes son las que avivan
la violencia un ejemplo es que el
gobierno israelí ha dispuesto el cierre
de los cruces de silboa y Salem en el
norte de cisjordania y ha suspendido
también los permisos de trabajo de
palestinos en la zona hasta nuevo aviso
el hecho de que uno de los palestinos
son fallecidos del miércoles fuera un
agente de inteligencia de la autoridad
Palestina llegó al Primer Ministro
israelí Jair lapid a insistir en una
posible escalada así el norte de
sijordania podría haber una
intensificación del círculo de violencia
con más redadas enfrentamientos y
muertes